the appreciation dissolves the boundary
of fear and appreciation creates more of
what you want so if you've got something
good going on go appreciate it even more
talk about it thrive in it write about
it feel it meditate on the feeling of it
because then you create more of it if
you're in a funk lean on what you
appreciate to get you out of that funk
and make appreciation a daily habit you
know like when you and josh go wake up
in the morning abraham hicks has this
thing called the appreciation game where
you can just play the appreciation game
and just say i appreciate you because
you make me coffee and i appreciate you
because you're a good dancer just really
appreciating your spouse your children
and play that game with your children oh
my goodness start your day going back
and forth with why you appreciate one
another and immediately just realigns
you puts you into this state where you
feel so good you can't feel bad in the
presence of appreciation and it will
catapult you out of the negativity and
that's what this is all about this is
all about taking these moments and using
these methods and these practices to
consciously and proactively bridge
yourself from that low vibration to a
better feeling emotion and in that
better feeling emotion you become a
super attractor need motivation watch a
top 10 with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best gabby bernstein and my take
on her top 10 rules for success enjoy
rule number two stay open to guidance i
went on my instagram and i was like how
many of you i did a
poll and i said how many of you are
blocking you're manifesting and 96
percent said yes whoa yeah and and
there's and i call it out i caught the
ways that we block and i and this whole
book is methods for unblocking and the
thing is is that you know the thing
that's most important is if to trust
that if you're watching this right now
that you are in in fact being guided so
even if you don't feel that guidance you
can't hear that inspiration there's no
way that you would have listened to this
specific podcast in this specific moment
if you were not indeed being guided
okay so just take that in fully and
completely and then your next step is to
recognize the guidance and then follow
the guidance you receive whether it's
read this book or not this book maybe
another book maybe after this podcast
you're led to another author on your
podcast and then that's the book that
you need or that's the the therapist
that you need to find it doesn't have to
be me but but but stay open and when
when you have an intuition to listen to
a podcaster it's when you're feeling
free and you make a decision to do
something it's when you're in a place of
of of
you know no agenda just a place of joy
inspiration relaxation and you start to
listen to something or a guy just that's
that's when you're really listening
that's when you're really receiving
guidance so i think anyone that's
listening to you is listening but they
just may not realize it rule number
three embrace difficult times i now have
deep appreciation for that dark hole i
was in six months ago because it's
giving me an opportunity to sit here
with you today and hopefully save some
lives yeah if there's a mother out there
that's watching and she's having
suicidal thoughts or she's having panic
attacks or she's having insomnia that
she can now go and talk to her ob gyn or
her psychiatrist i am deeply grateful
for for everything i've been through
through my addiction recovery from my
trauma healing through physical things
that i've talked about publicly because
they've given me a greater
level of compassion
for what people for the human condition
and a greater much greater opportunity
to speak and teach from a place of
authenticity so that's my my
appreciation for what has been and i
think if we start to look at the
difficult times in our lives and
appreciate them and also recognize them
as a learning device saying okay thank
you
alcoholism or thank you you know fear or
thank you drama in my life right now
because you're revealing to me
what i still need to heal rule number
four forgive yourself everyone has
unresolved areas where they are out of
alignment due to their upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted
so some people might be health some
people might be sex some people it might
be money some people it might be their
worth some people might be all of the
above whatever we've all got it we've
all got an area or many where we are
misaligned with
the feeling of love and abundance and
and grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay
so
the undoing of the lac mentality is a
journey of clearing
the belief systems from a experiential
time in your life right that happens
once again through books like the
universe has your back so fantastic that
you're doing that transform fear to
faith
excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural pathways
from the experiences that we've had as
children particularly young childhood
experiences but the good news is thanks
to neural plasticity our brain actually
can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our ptsd can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality we our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new behavior so
one thing that you can do simply in this
moment is to notice
when you are in that lac mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method i've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes i could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy which everyone i hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but what you can do
for yourself you're here for self-help
you're here for gabby to tell me how i
can serve myself
you can be in the proactive development
of new thought patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel
step two forgive yourself for having the
thought it's very simple up there's my
childhood story there's my parents lack
story again up there it is again
all right i forgive myself it just
showed up again because that forgiveness
will dissolve that guilt and tension and
fear that you're manifesting it all that
crap right
third step
choose the next best feeling thought
choose the thought of you know what i
just forgave myself for that thought so
i'm dissolving it in this moment i
actually am listening to the universe
has your back and it's so supportive
then i can actually go and listen to
super attractor so you can go from
thought to thought to thought to reach
for the next best feeling thought so
your willingness to face the slack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you
right and especially if you're feeling
afraid that you're manifesting things
because you're having the thoughts then
just forgive the thoughts because or
forgive yourself for having the thought
because the moment that you say oh i
forgive myself for that thought or i
forgive that thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized i am not that
thought it's just a thought that i keep
thinking i am not that belief it's just
a thought that i keep thinking also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five show up for your
wounds i think that
we all have uh in our own ways
unresolved
wounds from
attachment breach from childhood
experiences from feelings of being
unlovable and not good enough
they will continue to show up for us as
somatic experiences they'll show up in
our lives as gut conditions as
men as
as anxiety
disorders they may show up as insomnia
they may show up as back pain
they will show up until you show up for
them
in my life as a
human but also as a spiritual personal
growth teacher i have been in the
devotional commitment of showing up for
my
my
wounded part so that i can step into the
resourced
healthy whole part of who i am
the journey i've been on is nothing
short of a miracle i've i as you
mentioned earlier i was a drug addict in
my 20s
got sober at 25 just through my own
desire to be clean
then in my mid-30s i remembered i
remembered a dissociated traumatic event
from my childhood
that really put me on the path of
understanding why i used in the first
place to really understand why i was a
drug addict and
then really made the devotional
commitment to go further than my
spiritual practice and really start to
develop a therapeutic many therapeutic
practices for
helping myself get back to a healthy
baseline
and for restoring my nervous system and
grounding my energy so that i can be
where i am today lisa which is so
happy
so at ease so healthy and well and i i
wouldn't be able to be in this place now
if i hadn't had the opportunity to
do all the big lifting and heavy lifting
that i experienced before so i'm
grateful for the tough stuff because
it's revealed the great stuff now rule
number six undo the fear everyone that's
walking through this this world every
human being
they may not have had to have trauma
like we've had but they're walking
through life
feeling
unsafe
they may not have had sexual abuse or a
father that abandoned them maybe their
teacher told them they were stupid or
maybe
they you know they like
got lost one day in the parking lot when
they were a kid and didn't find their
mom it doesn't these subtle moments are
as of course in miracles says the
moments that we detour into fear they
call it the descent from magnitude into
littleness and we then create this form
of ego which is a separate mind separate
from god separate from love separate
from that freedom and it builds up a
pretense around us i mean i'm living in
it right now i'm watching a 10 month old
child so free of ego so free of fear and
i'm so conscious of every moment i'm so
conscious of not you know being on my
phone when i'm with him because i don't
want to create look i'm going to create
those moments he's going to have he's a
human having a human experience but i
want to hold him in the preciousness of
this god-like state as long as possible
right but that's not how people's
parents are right
yeah that's how we grew up right we grew
up we all grow up in this world where
there's just so each moment is an
opportunity to detour into fear and then
we create a world of
fear-based perceptions
and so what we must do to live and
thrive and feel good is undo those
fear-based perceptions and i believe
through a spiritual path or through
maybe a therapeutic i think spirit's in
all of it whether you realize it or not
but to make a commitment to feel better
it means that you're committed to
returning to
god um
or love or or you know spiritual
universe
rule number seven be inspired you might
agree with me on this like i can in one
hour i can do more than the average
person can do in a day or two days okay
and that's because
i do things from inspiration
and so when you're inspired you're in
spirit and you are expanding time you're
given more energy and
you just can get you know every things
download fast rule number eight replace
negative thoughts the voice within us
that believes that we are not allowed to
be happy
our card today is speaking to that
i believe i'm worthy of feeling good i
believe i am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to
suffer to succeed that we have to feel
pain to have purpose that we have to
have struggles in order to
feel a sense of serenity in our life
that is all
quite backwards it's when we feel good
that we actually attract more of what we
want into our life but we have to undo
the belief system that says who am i to
feel good who am i to feel great who am
i to be happy that belief system is an
ingrained belief system that can be
cultural that can be something that we
learned from our upbringing it can be
something that we have picked up from
this difficult experience that we're
going through right now with covid when
we witness people suffering we think
well how dare i be happy i would say to
you how dare you not be happy it's your
happiness it's the collective happiness
it's the group collective happiness that
raises the energetic frequency of the
world if we those of us who have moments
of happiness and grace and joy and
success and we don't celebrate them we
are doing the world a disservice we are
shutting down the light we are bringing
down the vibration so we have to when we
feel good we have to reach for more when
we feel good we have to recognize that
that good feeling emotion has momentum
it has power it elevates our children it
elevates our family members it elevates
our friends it elevates strangers on the
street it is your divine duty here on
earth to bring forth that greatness that
goodness that light so when you hear
that voice that says to you you are not
worthy of feeling good i want you to
hear my voice come through and say to
you
who are you not to feel good
this is your divine purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me
we are more comfortable being
uncomfortable than we are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a
solution-happiness-oriented mindset so
when that happens the next time you
notice that you're feeling good and all
is well and all of a sudden you're like
but i wasn't nice enough to that person
or my co-workers aren't in a good place
or i didn't do that right i want you to
speak back to that voice i want you to
say thank you for sharing but i choose
happiness instead
thank you for sharing but i don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but i'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and
grace sharing that happiness joy and
peace with so much grace
that's what you're here for rule number
nine unblock the guidance not only do i
talk about spirit guides and angels and
deceased family members but also talk
about your higher self so this is too
woo-woo for you
start to tap into what is the voice of
my higher self gotcha right that voice
of my inner guidance system and that
wisdom that i believe in is my is my
true nature right
but i i personally gabby bernstein i
believe that i that we all have
guides ancestors family members teachers
beings of light beings energy beings
that are supporting us in a in a form
that is is
able to step in able to channel through
us when we write books able to to be
there in those darkest moments pick us
up off the floor uh and and and hold us
in in discomfort and guide us to
business opportunities or babies or
whatever it is that we're looking for
and it's always available to us that
guidance but we just we cut it off we
block it
why do we block the guidance fear is the
reason we block it fear
it's not even fear it's that false-based
perception that we've built up around
ourselves from those traumatic events
right so we have these traumatic events
early in life and they continue to build
and build and build we build up a world
of uh false perceptions i am this body i
am gabby bernstein i am lewis howe i've
got the school of greatness
i can't trust people we we create these
beliefs and you believe you're separate
from others you believe you're you're
better than or less than or not good
enough and all those stories all those
those false pretenses are what what many
spiritual
practices called the ego right and that
fear-based perception of yourself is
misaligned with with with god with love
with spirit with angels with guides and
so this book is all about how to get
back into alignment so that you can hear
that guidance and receive that guidance
and be a
channel for inspiration and when you
when you clear
and undo those patterns of fear and
start to claim the pattern of love
that's when you are
hooked up super attractor
unstoppable unstoppable
invisible doors open for you it doesn't
matter how low you are when you're
starting this you will go way further
than you could possibly have imagined
and rule number 10 the last home before
some very special bonus clips is create
your reality and then the next question
i have for you is when you're thinking
about manifestation and calling in new
things are some of you manic manifesting
so this is really important
are some of you those folks who are like
i've got the list i've got the vision
board i've said it a thousand times i
told all my friends i want him i know
exactly what he looks like and i feel
like he's with me and we're walking down
the street together holding hands
you know who you are
you know who you are right you know
exactly who you are
look there's nothing wrong with being
clear
there's nothing wrong with being clear
but more importantly i want you to be
clear about how you want to feel and i
want you to just feel it
it's not about having the vision board
that's perfect it's not about having the
most amazing list you can do all that
work you can get clear you can be and if
anyone has a note of vision board it's a
beautiful board where you put all of
your images of what you want and plenty
of people spend a lot of time on that
board but they don't get into the energy
of what it feels like
and so they spend a lot of time with the
list and they spend a lot of time with
the board and they spend a lot of time
talking about it but they don't assume
the energy of what it feels like to be
in that manifestation now
assuming the energy of what it felt like
to pop off all your tops really helped
me call in something that will help me
do it
assuming that energy just brought me
into a state of being you are already
there sister you are already doing this
exactly as you are on your video blogs
in your lectures on twitter and facebook
you are already there and you want more
but you are already there
so acknowledging and accepting that i'm
already in the place that i am even
though i want it to be more i am already
there so if you want a romantic partner
make sure you have a real hot romance
with yourself
if you want more money
make sure you have a real good
relationship with the money you
currently have
if you want a new job make sure you have
a real good relationship with the job
you have today
everybody get that
people think oh well if i appreciate my
job that i have now then i'll only stay
there no absolutely not if you
appreciate the job that you have now
then you show up to that job with grace
you show up to that job with a good
attitude you show up that job with a
better approach you show up to that job
with more energy that job begins to
thank you that job says wait maybe
there's another job for you that job
then says here you're promoted here's
some more money have a great life
you
create your reality your intentions
create your reality so if you are
constantly in a place of thinking i hate
this i hate this i hate this you are
serving that
everybody's with me now i know you are
so rather than focusing on that manic
manifesting first and foremost get
honest if you are one of them if you are
please raise your hands now manic
manifesters just get honest people get
your hands up
manic manifesto so you're reading the
books you're doing the work you think
you think you think but your energy
what's your energy like scream it to me
what's your energy like
frantic
what was that
when you're saying when got it yes okay
what is your energy saying when your
energy's needy right it's controlling
it's manipulative
it's frightened
it's chaotic
what does that girl look like on a date
[Music]
so what is your energy doing how is your
manic manifesting affecting your genuine
manifestation
so i want you to get clear about that
and then the next piece here is just to
become super conscious and maybe take
yourself for the next 30 days where you
can use that exercise in my inkbook
where you put the little rubber band
around your wrist and you snap the
rubber band every time you catch
yourself talking about lack or you catch
yourself you know avoiding your finances
or you catch yourself eating the
hamburger or you catch yourself manic
manifesting just check yourself before
you wreck yourself
and sl and snap
your wrist right so take that little
everybody got that
you hear yourself you're in the
conversation with your girlfriend and
you're like oh my god i can't get it i
don't know what's going on the man won't
call me back i can't kill myself oh my
god and then all of a sudden instead of
continuing
snap the rubber band
i say i forgive myself
for my lack mentality i forgive myself
for my fear i choose to see this
differently
that's it
you don't need to figure out what to see
differently you just need to say i
choose to see this differently and you
will be given all you need to see
something differently
we live in a world that reinforces a
scarcity mentality and that mentality
keeps us an energy of lack it keeps us
from attracting the career path that we
want the abundance that we want and
allowing us to really live our purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life we all
have stories from our childhood how our
parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough and if we feel like we
don't have enough we do a lot of work to
try to prove to the world that we are
enough the second block is the belief
system that there's not enough to go
around
we often overwork to try to get it all
we're constantly trying to get get get
because we don't believe that there is
enough it makes us feel like we have to
work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison
we
literally just turn on our social media
and we're immediately into compare
compare compare
and comparing blocks are attracting
power because it focuses us on what we
don't have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win
in the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
when we fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want
but it's important to understand that
rejection can be protection
when we have some form of rejection show
up in our life it's the universe guiding
us to something better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself now
that you know the six blocks to
abundance i want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to float to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment
so if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
the more we are in that service
mentality the more positively the
universe responds to us this puts you
into an abundance mentality quickly
because the more you give the more you
will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous you're no
longer separating yourself from others
redirect your focus from what can i get
to how do i feel and really allow that
feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire i get a call from my one of
my team members and she's like uh don't
go on facebook i was like what she's
like
there's a whole
person's facebook page and they're
railing on you and they're going off
about you
and
maybe like 30 people had chimed in being
like oh you hate gabby bernie thank god
somebody's talking about it
just like you know going after me yeah
and
well 30 people is a small number in the
grand scheme of the universe this feels
really overwhelming and and even one
person hating you on the internet can
can shake you to your core
so i
lo i just i do what anyone would do in
that moment and i start to go down that
hole of of shame and upset and what did
i do wrong and how could i have
triggered these people in this way and
what you know what is my part and just
getting so hooked into it even though
you know a lot of what was being said
was being said without any information
right uh you know but regardless i
didn't even need to dig into it to feel
the feelings of discomfort and i was
getting really really hung up about it
really hung up about it and took you
know probably it was about a full day of
just like being down and bummed out and
i remember i was watching television
with my husband at night i was staring
at my phone just being like did more
people weigh in like what's happening
and he looked at me he's like what is
going on what you can't even be present
with me in this room why are you so
stuck in this i was like it feels so
horrible to be
you know pounded on on the internet and
i'm so upset about it and he said listen
you've got it all wrong girl this is
where my husband became my guru he said
you are focusing all your energy on
these 30 people who are hating you but
you have thousands of people on your dm
on instagram that are trying to send you
love that are asking you questions that
want your support and you don't even
know how to find your dm
you and me were in the same boat for a
long time
yeah yeah and he's like you don't even
know how to find it he's like let me
show you how to find your dm and focus
on the people that need you not on these
people that are hating on you so
i spend the next four days just dm'ing
dm'ing dm like i went on my instagram i
was like yo who wants to dm like let's
go
and so i'm just like in it and i'm just
feeling so like within 48 hours i was
just like so transformed by just being
in the service of others and connecting
to the people that really wanted to to
hear from me and wanted my support and
what happened that was so so
transformational was i woke up one
morning a few days into this and i woke
up at like 5am and i was i was upset by
the still a little yeah the thought came
right back in oh there they are why are
they talking about me of course and in
that moment i was like okay zach said
get on dm so i get back on my dm and i
start dming and i see this girl and
she's talking to me and she's saying you
know listen i um was sober for two years
i just went out i feel like i'm i want
to commit suicide right now i started
dming with her within the hour i'm on
the phone with her
and
that day she made a commitment to go
back to recovery
so i have
deep gratitude for those haters because
those haters gave me this beautiful
opportunity of service to somebody and
potentially save her life
and and and and also just get over it
i've been really working on getting
honest and telling the truth and being
forthcoming about how i'm feeling
i know this is something that can be
very squirrely for people we can get
really hung up about actually saying how
you feel and telling the truth but when
we don't tell the truth we actually
stifle our energy we create toxic
relationships we carry resentments and
it builds up and builds up and builds up
so i've gotten into the practice of this
just radically telling the truth
wherever i am however i need to be
authentic and truthful about what i'm
feeling but i have a few steps that i
think are important that you need to
take in before you actually give that
truth over because if you share your
truth without cleaning up your side of
the street it'll feel like an attack
it'll feel like judgment so the process
of telling the truth is quite simple
first take a look at your side of the
street look at what's up for you if you
feel called to get honest with somebody
what is it within you that's feeling
triggered what is it that's that's
feeling activated and do whatever you
need to do to clear that whether it be
forgiving yourself forgiving the other
person saying prayers for that other
person sending loving energy to that
other person and clean up the energy
before you bring over the truth because
you don't want to show up with this
nasty attitude because your truth won't
be heard you need to bring your truth
with a lot of light so that they can see
their light reflected back to them
so the process is really simple look at
your side of the street before you show
up and tell the truth and then be
prepared to get honest from a place of
love if you can tell the truth from a
place of love then you will be heard and
that's when you feel healed and that's
when a healing can be offered up to the
relationship but as long as you're
telling the truth from a place of
negativity or judgment it will not be
heard and it won't work i learned this
the hard way unfortunately but the
experience has given me this great
opportunity to learn how to tell the
truth with grace and power
the benefit of telling the truth is that
you start to feel like you're taking
care of yourself you start to feel like
you're owning your voice you're owning
your needs you're protecting yourself
when you need to protect yourself and
you're sticking up for what your values
are no matter what and you're also just
you know really getting clear about what
your boundaries may be within certain
relationships and so sometimes people
may not like your truth but you can
always trust that if you're sharing your
truth from a place of love you will be
heard even if they get defensive even if
they get upset that your loving presence
is enough to allow that truth to come
through in a very authentic way
the other part that may be very helpful
is once you've told your truth give the
person their opportunity to tell their
own hold that space for them to say how
they feel there's always two sides to
every story so speak up and then allow
the other person to speak up clearing
that space for the truth to unfold and
trusting that the truth will totally set
you free my mom has always said this to
me for my entire life the truth will set
you free the truth will set you free and
i believe that we all want freedom we
want freedom from resentment freedom
from anxiety freedom from fear and that
freedom is available as we start to open
up to the truth within us
there's no such thing as a mistake
everything happens in divine order i am
being guided to learn and grow here we
go people
when we look at the situations in our
life from a place of regret
we ultimately miss the opportunity for
growth we miss the opportunity to see
what could have been
beneath that discomfort we miss the
opportunity to acknowledge and recognize
that every experience in our life is not
an accident it doesn't happen by
accident it happens in a divine order
and when we live and lead and show up
for our life
grounded in that belief system
then we can face our most
difficult moments
with a
sense of purpose and power
and we can show up for those moments
with a opportunity to grow focusing on
the opportunity to grow focusing on the
opportunity for a shift for strength for
spiritual awakening for a new way of
being and a new perception of our lives
so that's a lot i know that's a lot i
know that when something really bad
happens like what we've been
experiencing recently in the world what
we experienced in the united states last
week when we experienced something like
a pandemic we don't want to see the
spiritual assignment we don't want to
see that this is not a mistake
but typically when difficult things
happen they are revealing what needs to
be healed these uncomfortable moments
whether they be global or they be
personal are revealing what we have to
heal whether we have to heal it on an
individual level which is where it
begins and what we have to heal on a
global perspective on a global level so
showing up to all these uncomfortable
moments and recognizing them that they
are not a mistake that they are
happening in a divine order and it's our
opportunity
to perceive these situations from the
lens of what can i learn from this how
can i grow from this how can i shift
from this how can i lean towards more
love how can i lean towards more joy how
can i lean into the lesson rather than
the problem the solution rather than
seeking all of the faults and and
looking for all of the problems i'm in
this three-year journey of trying to
conceive and
really for
year and a half almost two years i was
like in the low of it really feeling
like okay i'm not good enough my body
isn't working how can i make this happen
how can i make this happen right and
really pushing and controlling and
trying to eat things and
track my ovulation and all that crap and
then about the fall of 2017 i started to
get into more of a surrendered state and
i started practicing the methods that i
teach in the book of just really
trusting that there
was
a
higher guidance that i've believed in
for my whole life and relying on that
and that's when things started to get
really wild and synchronistic and so
around the fall of 2017 i was driving in
the countryside where i lived most of
the time and this is where i do the
majority of my manifesting is just
driving in the car looking at the
foliage listening to my mantra music and
i feel so awesome when i'm in that
position and i'm just so grateful in the
moment and i'm driving and i'm driving
i'm like i feel so awesome and so
grateful that i live in this country
town i have all these friends and i
don't have any cell service right now
and i'm so psyched about that and no
one's bothering me and i feel good and
then all of a sudden i felt the presence
of a baby in the back seat
and i was like
wow like deeply moved tears started to
roll down my face i felt so moved
and at that point i heard my intuition
say to me
the baby's coming in march
and i was like and it was so loud like
you know when you hear the voice of your
inspiration you're like that's it okay i
believe and so i started saying to
myself over and over like oh my god
march you know i have to conceive at
this time for the baby to come and watch
i saw myself getting a little into it
like too into it and hooked into it so i
said okay listen you know what universe
i'm gonna give this over and if my baby
is indeed coming in march show me a sign
show me lily's to let me know that the
baby's coming in march
and a week later i got a letter in the
mail from a reader and it had this angel
card in it and on the back of it was
this picture of archangel gabriel and
archangel gabriel is typically depicted
holding lilies so i was like yo this is
dope and on the back he wrote
i thought that you needed this i was
like thank you good so here i am march
march is coming march is happening and
early march rolled around and i wasn't
pregnant so i was like what the hell and
not only was i devastated once again
another month has gone by i'm not
pregnant but this time i was like i
thought the universe had my back like i
was getting signs like what what's the
uh what's up
so i walked into my husband's office and
i was just hysterically crying so upset
so defeated
and at some my phone was like on the
desk like right here
and all of a sudden my phone started
playing a song
and the song was just repeating
repeating it's like go like you know
when your phone malfunctions you're like
i'm just gonna turn that off i was like
okay i'm just gonna turn out and then i
look at the phone and i start listening
to the lyrics and the lyrics are
way go lily
way go lily and the guy keeps repeating
way go lily and then i look even further
and i look at the name of the song as we
go lily and he keeps repeating lily and
i look even further and the album title
is i see the sign
and where was this playing where what
area of your phone this was just my
phone just turned on oh no that's it's
you know it's spirit working through the
technology and so my phone just turned
on it was an album that i'd never heard
i'd never heard the song before it
wasn't in my spotify and it just began
playing now get this
so i get i april rolls around and i'm
pregnant
but then i did the math and i was like
when did i conceive
i conceived the last day of march
so that
synchronicity you know you hear march
you find your signs you feel super
guided
that synchronicity is available to all
of us but it's when it had we have to
get out of that pusher mentality and out
of that controlling behavior to allow
the presence of spirit to work through
us and guide us and or the universe or
whatever use whatever you call it to be
the presence of of of direction
inspiration
to be that guide many of us have issues
with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been so i hit a bottom
recently with this productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways i was
then blessed i said a prayer i said i
need some help with my brain fog and i
need some help with my productivity
issue and i that day got an email from
the dr oz show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
doctor dr mike dao and me and mike had
been in touch many years
for many years just because he hadn't
been author we were published by the
same publishers and mike had written a
book about brain fog
so that day i'm like thank you universe
you're giving me exactly what i need i
go on dr oz with mike and i'm backstage
with him and i'm like listen i'm feeling
so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm i'm forgetting things and he looked
at me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one and then once i
complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
gonna do five things i have been more
productive i have created more have been
more intuitive i have been more inspired
and i've been more creative as i commit
to happiness fully
exactly what i need is coming towards me
because i become a magnet i become an
energy field that is so magnetizing that
is so excited that so inspired
that other people want to support and
work with that energy and so when we
dwell in the energy of joy and happiness
we become a magnet for that which we
desire so my hope for you all is to
start to think about the things that you
want to succeed in whether it's
succeeding in romantic relationships or
succeeding in your career or succeeding
in your health goals and make a
commitment today to bring more joy
to that area of your life rather than
seeing it as a struggle rather than
pushing forward with all this angst and
negativity and neediness and control
just bring joy to it
your successes will come when you commit
to joy when you commit to happiness so
find more joy in that physical exercise
i've been going to soul cycle i
absolutely love it it's so joyful for me
and that's helping me raise my butt
because that was one of my goals and
success and and then we have these
moments where we want to really bring
joy into our career well if you're
having a hard time in the office just
find ways to have more fun and as we
start to elevate that presence of joy we
will begin to magnetize the successes in
our life and so take this very seriously
bring this practice into your day-to-day
experiences and make joy and happiness
your number one priority and recognize
how your successes will be brought to
you in a form far greater than you could
ever imagine when your primary focus is
happiness when you fully accept that you
are here to be great when you fully
accept that you are here to be happy
when you fully accept that you are here
to receive when you fully accept that
you can
have
the peace and the serenity and the joy
and the wisdom and the purpose and the
intention that you intend to bring to
the world and that it is all available
to you
that's when life gets very groovy
and so my hope and my intention for
today
is to wake you up to that presence
i more importantly give you a really
great new york city kick in the ass that
says not only i'm awake to it not only
do i believe in it
but i am committed to it
i am unapologetic about my capacity to
be great i am unapologetic about my
capacity to heal i'm unapologetic about
my capacity to see beyond my physical
sight i'm unapologetic about my capacity
to shine as bright as i can shine
because i trust and i know that when i
shine bright i give others permission to
do the same and in my glow they wake up
too and that
is why we're here
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to watch
my recent 101 sit down with gabby
bernstein check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there trauma is very delicate and we all
have it you rip off the band-aid too
fast
you'll get blown out
it'll be too too scary at once we all
have the capacity to be of service to
others